all right repeat it's all yours all
right my mom my mom grew up in a
Louisiana and she had two brothers and
all through our childhood we hear about
hospitality you know people in Louisiana
were they treated you you know and made
you welcome welcome to where you'd want
to go back my mom used to drink like a
fish until my father died in 67 I
remember looking up at my mom first time
I can't remember seeing her cry and
because my father was dead I didn't know
the reason and from that day on she
never took another drink
you know where we are where I grew up I
had to well I was always like a somebody
in challenging I was challenged in
school to where I wanted the highest
grade I wanted to higher score I wanted
to finish my test first I wanted to get
more answers right so I was like a
competition thing always with me and I
would realize and that I wouldn't know
anyone competing then all of us was
competing in fourth grade we were
introduced to algebra and it was so
exciting at that age because it's
something we didn't know and the
individual mathematician who started
teaching us algebra and in the fourth
grade he would come once a week and he
would give us these problems that were
phenomenal and he would give us this he
wouldn't give us a the answer but he
would give us a solution
and we work solution all of us would
come up with appropriate answer but
there were other individuals who didn't
want us to achieve so I literally had to
fight to get to school because oh you
think you smart never know I'm not smart
in anybody else I'm just try harder and
I just remember so I had to fight to get
to school and then the same people were
waiting for me after school so I had to
fight to leave so I figured if I had to
fight to get in if I had to get out of
my stuff oppression well first might as
well learn something because I'm
fighting for it anyway so in junior high
school was when my change change of life
started and again it started when I
started scuba diving my diet partner my
instructor my teacher my mentor was some
bath man why God and he's been to Nam
and I mean this guy was to me he was
Einstein and I would listen to the
conversation man I'm out of there I'm
out of the ghetto and I'm general
conversation but I would hear you know
these affluent people I mean me and as
being heirs karlie what you want I would
hear them talk and I was so amazed at
the conversation I said one one day I
may have conversations like that so I
aspire to increase my vocabulary
I started aspiring to learn and with
that inspiration with every game every
game brings its own problems you know I
was always told you think you're smarter
than everybody else I said I'm not
smarter I just try harder you think
you'd ever you think you better I'm not
better I'm just different you know I'm
just different from who and what you are
because I think different
anyway uh anything you consistently do
is supposed to get better at so I did a
lot of fighting I did a lot of fighting
I knew I had to fight you know
and anything you keep doing again you
get better at so I got somewhat better
at it when I came out of prison I met
somebody who changed my life for a
little while you know she was absolutely
said he was so beautiful to me I mean to
the rest of the world - but she was from
I would meet at Pershing Square when
she'd come from work or whatever I meet
me and I would walk her back in here I
really didn't like her over here because
she didn't really belong but on the way
here from president Square to San Pedro
I mean individual would make them the
strangest comments like what they wanted
to do to her sexually and I would hear
this and I would turn around and what
did you say and I'm not talking about
I'm talking to her and one thing I
learned in the military was whoever
strikes first and strikes hard and
consistently strikes has the greatest
opportunity or possibility of being
victorious so conversation over I would
take off our right hook left whatever
and there's one particular incident when
this guy came down the street he was
looking for trouble we had his shirt off
he kind of pinch and rebuff and I'm
standing there talking to the two
security guards in a particular program
where they allow people use the bathroom
24 hours and some talking to them and
with him coming so we stopped and we
look and he's like yeah I'm [ __ ] me
one of these he used the n-word which I
really detest I mean in prison all my
years in prison we had a lot of battles
over that word a lot of good people died
bad people whatever so I particularly
tell people I mean I don't care what
your conversation about but when you're
talking to me don't use them
and don't call me that because that's
one thing I aspire not to be I try hard
not to fit that life to fit not to wear
that jacket so anyway he uh stops in
front in front of me in them he says
yeah imma [ __ ] with somebody up who
gonna be my first victim and he turns
around he looks at me I'm standing on
his folded and he says you gonna be my
first victim I said okay nope took my
coat uh put my bag down and when it was
over he looked different he felt
different he knew you know because a guy
had asked me later he said when you hit
him and he went down what was your
thinking I said I was thinking I wasn't
gonna let him back up we're gonna buy
opportunist and back up again because I
kept striking in the particular area I
grew up in I had no idea that this area
had become a gang and it was basically
like forties I had no idea I'm in prison
and a younger individual I knew from
that location he came and said that's
where we are and I'm trying to think
what what is that what is what does it
represent all week rips on us and uh I
mean I'm from there by location not
affiliation I'm not gonna do it that way
I'm gonna keep my particular walk
nothing to get involved in the gang
activity I mean I got your back and you
know I have everybody else back that I
know if and when it comes to it but I'm
not finished going to the gang part of
it one particular day and I think this
was like 1984 and 84 I had met this
female and she wanted to not sexually be
involved because she was a lesbian which
is no problem I'm a lesbian too
she wanted to you know take up with me
and make some money with me to get away
you know so sell drugs so I gave her a
little something and left and I came
back came back about an hour later to
see how she was doing and I went off
into her I went off in the store I came
out and I looked across the street and I
know the woods wasn't there when I went
in it was a crowd and so I looked at the
crowd and I seen her in the middle of
the crowd I seen her just stipulate
moving her head and shaking her body you
know wondering what was going on and I
see this guy had never seen before he
walks up to it he's talking to her any
pushes her but thinking what the [ __ ]
so I cross the street through traffic
and I walk up and she said here comes
Pete now and you gonna get it and they
look at me and I notice two girls I'd
never seen before
they back up and one goes in a little
clutch person she pulled out a snub 38
she hands it to that one she sticks in
their pocket and you know we got me
covered that's all right we're gonna do
it this way I said I'll be back running
down the street go through a shortcut my
younger brothers shooting dice with some
friends I said come on man would let's
roll call him Hollywood that's wrong man
my [ __ ] drew down them and they drew
it out I said they drew down on man
let's go we go out to the next block get
in the car I reached under the dashboard
grab the Python opening up is loaded I
took it I said pull around to mom's
house put in the driveway so we
negotiate the turns he pulls in the
driveway I get out the car says meet me
at the stop sign wait for me right there
so I marched down the middle of the
street into main trafficking to Figaro
and I'm standing there and I'm looking
for the individuals I don't see them
y'all into girls I catch them on my free
field in a city they're about to make a
left turn and come by me act like I
don't see them for another couple of
seconds and I reaching and I grab it and
are going to the stands and I'm going to
the stands they ducked down but see I
know that the rounds from a 357 is going
to go through a car door it go through
an engine block
so I sight over the chrome stripping on
a 64 Chevy and I put two rounds above
the chrome stripping and when I dropped
the one under the chrome stripping the
person pops up a female pops up she been
hitting she's frelling her arms so the
guy grabs her he throws her over and he
jumps and drops if he's looking up and
down like he's trying to get it in gear
and so now I'm thinking I might as well
blow it up so I try to get the gas tank
I put two rounds in the gas tank don't
go up and he negotiates to turn tips a
car pulls down the street and I take out
the back window I never understood why
about three blocks down a shooting the
air to top I guess he was suing don't
pursue me we got something too so anyway
uh everybody in traffic it just
everybody jumped out to the cars and ran
out I'm out what it did same thing they
evacuated the cars and they're down the
street feeling so I walked back over to
my brother's probably get in and we
drive off we had approximately I'd say
somewhere around 15 shoot ups and when I
say should I mean you know us shooting
at somebody else and they're shooting at
us and the thing with me is when the
military trains on something they put a
couple of thousand years of science and
untold billions of dollars into them you
know the training session so if you
listen then the best experts in the
world on how to kill how to make sure
the bullet goes where as opposed to a
ballistic arts and everything else and I
just take these things into
consideration especially Kentucky
windage when you find see where your
round is going if it's shot lift if is
if it's if it's going far dear Lord
something so I didn't draw down on a lot
of people because the thing was in our
neighbor if you draw down you're gonna
use the worst thing you can do is draw
down on somebody pull out a pistol and
not use
then you fall into another category
where you got a pair so you were
drawdown but you won't use it you have
to use it there are a few things that
I've accomplished and these are good
things things I'm proud of now that I
think about them as an adult I wish I'd
never done them can't go back and scrub
the past or live them for the future to
finally pass the message on if one
person get it and can't avoid you know
what I've been through what I'm still
going through then fantastic if nobody
can't avoid what I went through
no gonna put the message out there and
this medium is turned out to be one of
the best things that ever happened to me
because there are a lot of unexpected
surprises I ran into a guy I never knew
but he knew me he knew me from watching
this uh watch his program and and I was
amazed I still carry that with me to
where you know he wanted my autograph
and I never thought I'd see anything
like that but he got the message he said
your story was great I mean me and my
wife loved it I mean you know you knew
what you were talking about it was real
and we loved it we told a lot of our
friends and they pass it on I've shared
with my family my son should be getting
out of a incarcerated situation real
soon I didn't know he was there my niece
Rose she was telling me you need to
check on your son you need to find out
what's going on with him something's
wrong and I really didn't get the
message because I was kind of well not
too busy I was preoccupied would my own
you're your life drops and downs
his mom's been trying to reach out to me
and I'm not taking that trip again so I
really don't feel what I don't want to
because I would never ever go through
that cycle again it was a bad time in my
life but nothing compares to what I
recently went through the individual I
was with the female I was working yeah
just whatever reason told me that uh she
needed some extra money and a lot of it
it was critical for me because it was
like she was daring me to go back to
yesterday to relive the past
and I'm the type of person I can look at
some things and I can figure out a way
to achieve an objective so at this time
I did probably 12 acts in 12 days and
David was she asked for a lot of it and
it was for her to achieve her escape
one thing she said she always told me
that I was too violent and for her she
was right because I actually dropped
behind I'd take off on somebody but I
wouldn't go looking for trouble they'd
have to say something something
derogatory towards her and disrespectful
to me so what she did was she claims her
loss her house key so I gave her mine
and when out today came back knocking on
the door I couldn't get in I don't know
if anybody was home she was home but she
was unquiet silent running
I saw left went grocery shopping came
back a couple of dollars worth of food
and I'm still trying again I know she'll
pop up so I sit there a little while
later the police show up when they show
up the way they come in I know I'm
there's no doubt about it I know they're
coming for me I just can't figure out
why what did I do
so you know they draw down lay me down
the hallway cuffed me up and take me out
to the car and say I violated a
restraining order
there's no restraining order against me
but it was what she told him that she
had a restraining order didn't however
when they put me in the car I gave him I
gave him I got my Bunco I got my alias
they typed it in and he said no let's
try this name and when he put my real
name in there was no doubt in my mind
that she had given it to me she set this
whole move up and I could not understand
why so I mean when something's too
difficult to understand I I stopped
trying I stopped trying to understand
either it'll come to me I won't but what
she did was she got rid of me she got
rid of me so that she could make her
egress and she did I did a little time
in little Beirut what they call the
county jail because when you when you go
in LA County you might not live to get
out and it's a racial riot just about
every day and I'm a little bit well a
lot older then I wasn't a win as an
youngster looking forward to these
activities I don't look forward to him
because not everybody lives to get wrong
the county jail they have their rules
and regulations but
each race has a variety of rules and
regulation that makes it so much more
unbearable so much harder for an
individual to get through so as an older
individual they usually put us in the
old man's dorm where there's a lot less
politics or myself a veterans dorm so
then when the veterans doing with
watered-down politics there's still
politics but they're watered down I came
out of the county jail and I ran into a
couple of times and just decided to let
her go and I and I have I think about it
but I decided let it go however for a
while I was on that uh I was on that
self-destruction mode
I was literally really really trying to
be destroyed I didn't want to do it
myself
somebody's gonna facilitate me
somebody's going to help me so I did a
lot of things I wouldn't normally do I
mean II wouldn't evil did all those
stunts because he didn't give a [ __ ] I
didn't give a [ __ ] I put myself in a lot
of perilous situations with people not
not not not the police I really don't
deal with him I avoid them at all cost I
put myself in some situations I mean I
put out a gang of money let three guys
follow him into the alleys just to see
how I was going to turn out as it turned
out I came out they didn't I don't know
where I was psychologically but that
self-destruct and then you know the mind
altering mood changing substances they
were they were great not on the courage
factor but on the ability to
stay focused for a while because after
that I mean dear to the world my there
are there's 11 of us in my family live
was 11 til my brothers died a year apart
but at age 21 they they went out in
tremendous fashion and what I mean by
that is I mean heartbreaking that
changed my mother's life it changed our
family structure changed everything we
used to be tighter than the skin on a
golf ball I mean have you ever tried to
fill a golf ball somewhere along the
line we but the older ones gravitated
toward their own interests and this
family fell apart
I really don't communicate with my
family I mean a couple of members you
know and a few everyone's hi and bye how
are you doing my younger brother is here
wouldn't we we don't get along but I
love him he loves me I'm not gonna let
nothing happen to him he's not gonna let
nothing happen to me if it does then
it's gonna be it's gonna be reppin
it's gonna be repercussions
I just started back well trying to talk
to my daughter
I can't tell you how that's going
because I have no idea I just take it as
it comes
I'm not necessarily winning I am
maintaining the purpose and it's just
about time for me to get up out of here
not because this place is any different
from any other place I mean you have got
a lot of people doing nothing and a lot
of drugs and everything else I mean just
concentrated but I can do from here the
same thing I can do for me anywhere else
if I made up my mind to when I decide to
and I've made that decision I'm gonna
escape Alcatraz you know escape from
here I'm going to Monday I should be
back at home I should be back at work
I'm going there they'll rehire me I mean
I didn't leave under bad conditions on
that for the good conditions and I work
hard I can and I will
I'm not leaving this because uh because
I'm scared I'm not leaving because I'm
tired I'm leaving it because there's a
graduating process I mean upward and
onward and
I'm going to show a few other people how
I don't know the reasons for being here
the reason for living
the reason for leaving I mean I I don't
know but what I do know as I have
grandchildren now that I've never
physically seen never spoken to being
about I've been on this side about four
years I've never embraced him I've never
shaken him I've never sat down and ate
with him I've never taken him anywhere
I've never personally anything I've
never met him other than a phone
conversation a couple of minutes cos
it's for me it's so uncomfortable and it
should be it's supposed to be it's
supposed to be uncomfortable because I
put it off for so long I have six
grandchildren and I've never met one of
them
the only person I've actually seen was
my second elders my son I haven't seen
my daughter ever seen my youngest but
I'm going to there are some things that
I well I was thinking at one time that
leaving here I had to clean up a few
messes that you know I've encountered a
few people and I really was I mean I had
it not mapped out because you don't have
to map it out here I'll run into him and
I I was going to let a few people down a
few of them but I've decided not to I'm
not I'm not going to that's not my
position that's not I I can't do another
31 years I can't do a number 31 days in
prison I don't want to
I got something else to do and I I've
listened to a lot of individual stories
on the air and I thought I had it hard
everybody had it hard now on individual
way because when the strong get hungry
the weak don't eat I mean you get fed
down here but we're talking in Darwin's
theory of the fittest you can really see
it here no matter who when an individual
first came here I told him I said if you
got any property that you want to keep
when you leave put on your back and take
it with you you even wonder why I had
three or four backpacks I said because
everything in here is something I want
to maintain now tell me if you don't
want it
just leave it it'll disappear on its own
it'll go go to where the dinosaur I
don't want to do any more fighting down
here I mean I'm not a good runner so I'm
not gonna run but I've tried a different
way to avoid conflict it felt strange it
felt funny felt like I was I think the
word is eating crow and I felt kind of
when I kind of I felt humiliated just by
backing down I mean I had no doubt in my
mind I would it turned out they look
different and felt different but I just
didn't want to and I wanted to try it
another way
and I tried it it didn't feel good at
first but I think in time it's supposed
to come easier to avoid conflict to walk
away from it instead of go head-on into
it I'm obviously a lot older I'm not as
handsome as I once thought I was I'm not
as quick as I believed to be I'm not as
skilled as I want to be those aren't the
reasons why
don't wanna participate anymore the
reason why I don't want to participate
anymore is because I'm searching for a
new purpose a new direction I can't say
that new purpose in a new direction is
going to be better but I can't say it's
going to be different and it starts for
me making different decisions you know
the saying trying to know doing the same
thing a different way it doesn't work
out well to get new results I have to
try new things and Monday I start on
something new no it won't make it out of
here Monday but I will go to work Monday
and that's a great beginning for me I
haven't done it in a while but I'm going
to most people want to go to SSI I could
do that but I don't want to because
there's still some work left in there
and that's what I want to go do this
time I've made my decision know if
you'll see me because I've seen some
people come through and talk about you
know how they actually sleep right here
as you do that and it's just so amazing
that bringing a family to show them
where they being what they've done and
it's one of those success stories and I
plan on being one I'm I'm not going to
do fantastic I will definitely all right
we were yeah Monday I go back to
you